hey what's up guys my name is channel
welcome back to the game engine
series we are back and we are going to
be doing
a little bit of a different format so
let me know what your thoughts are below
as we get into this because i've just
slowly been realizing that um like i
you know the way that the game engine
series is going at the moment it's very
kind of detailed it's very like me
writing code in front of you guys which
is just not going to scale well as we
get into more complex features in the
engine
and the way that i see things at least
for myself you know i have to make
decisions this isn't like some company
this isn't like a
team of people behind us it's just me
making this series and i need to kind of
um you know make sure that i've got time
for other things such as
you know the actual development of hazel
like hazel dev and all of that stuff
actually
making a proper game engine being able
to make a game with it hopefully
and i feel like the way that we're
moving along with the game engine series
is just a little bit too slow
um so i've decided to change things up a
bit i did put up a video
there'll be a link up there regarding
like what's going on with the game
engine series in general
and we are basically going to be
following that course so what i've done
is i've actually already worked on
like um you know some features which
we'll talk about now
they're already integrated i'm about to
push them to github
and i'm going to just walk you through
the work that i've already done
instead of you watching me do all of the
work now i'm going to try my best to
make this as detailed as possible we're
basically moving
moving from like you know line by line
tutorial series
style videos to like you know devlogs
post-mortems but very in-depth ones not
like the hazel dev ones where i just
show you guys the features
talk about my story my journey all of
that i'll do that as well but this will
be like
you know we will walk through the code
i'll show you some things that i learned
along the way
you know that kind of stuff and also
hopefully um give you some insights into
into decisions that were made however if
you want to actually see
every line of code being written every
decision being made
you can do that because i've streamed
everything that i've done here
on twitch.tv slash the channel there'll
be a link in the description to that
live stream
i'm making the video on them like the
the videos the vods
um public for everyone right they used
to be only for twitch subscribers
as of right now um well i need to
actually
flick the switch but before this video
goes up i'm going to change it to public
so
if it's been within 60 days because
twitch only keeps them for 60 days
um you can actually watch all of the
vods if you want that
um you'll have to like i've labeled them
mostly game engine series if they're
about the game engine series and not
about other stuff that i stream like
just
hazel dev kind of development you know
that kind of stuff so it should it
should be like
fairly easy to find hopefully past 60
days though i do upload them to patreon
um like to youtube and like give access
to patreons
so there'll be a link in the description
as well patreon.com
um best way to help support you know my
series and everything that i'm doing
here and you'll also get access
to those kind of past live streams
forever they're not going to expire
because they're uploaded to youtube so
um that's basically the scope of things
but anyway let's stop talking let's dive
into the code i'll show you guys what's
new and what's changed
so first of all actually um let's talk a
little bit about where we left off last
time i think we were doing like mouse
picking stuff and that had pretty much
finished
and the next stage was really working on
the material system
now i just want to say that like a
material system is kind of
something that applies a lot more to a
3d engine this
like hazel is a 3d engine the way i see
it is it is a 3d engine
like at the moment we're kind of doing
2d rendering i mean it's still kind of
in 3d space but it's we're trying to
keep it
two-dimensional even though our
rotations and everything are
very much 3d i think at the moment and
we've got a 3d camera
but the point is we're focusing on 2d
rendering and like a full 2d workflow
that's kind of our goal
but we still need the system the
underlying system to be
3d right like as in it needs to support
a 3d workflow
and the way that we typically render
things is by using materials
um and if you're not sure what a
material is and how it needs to exist
and all that there's a video up there i
did talk about this and it was kind of
like a game engine series episode
although it was a live stream
um you can you can take a look at that
video and see how like what materials
are and all of that
but basically in order to support a
material system we need a better shader
system because materials are basically
shaders and
and a bunch of data as well to go along
with that so um
what i've done is i've basically changed
the whole way that we
deal with shaders so let's take a look
at that so um
basically if i launch this just to be um
you know just to show that this actually
works
and of course it's recompiling stuff i
don't know why anyway if i open up
like you know pink cube.hazel um you
know you can see that everything is
basically exactly the same as it used to
be nothing has changed since the last
episode we can still click on stuff
obviously
and pick stuff but the underlying shader
system has changed entirely
and that's what we're going to walk
through now i do have diffs here
like if we look through all of this this
is what's changed as i mentioned i
haven't committed anything
this is going to go right into the
master branch but i haven't committed
anything
um so we can actually walk through these
diffs in future episodes where maybe i
do actually commit from time to time
we can go through like you know the
commit log basically
and see everything um so that'll be okay
but i'll just more or less
share the code if you really want to see
the diff you know you can go to a
particular commit and view it
there's actually a question i get pretty
often is like how do i view you know
this particular episode or whatever um
if you actually go to github
um you know there's this kind of commits
over here right you can click on this
and then it will actually take you to
all of these things so for any of these
you can just click
on this hash here and actually view
the diff of everything that's changed
but you can also browse the repository
at a particular point in history so i
can go back
to like literally like you know the
first episode or whatever i don't know
if i'll go back that far
um because that's like that's a while
but if i go back to like i don't know
somewhere like here dispatching events
from jfw
i can click this browse repository
button and you can see this is this is
the repository from that point in time
so like
you know sandbox probably looks very
bare bones um yeah that's it right there
is no hazelnut application so you can
actually
you know you can check that out if you
uh if you have it checked out locally
just like in fork right click checkout
commit
um you know or you can do it through the
command line or if you're just browsing
it through github you can also do that
so there's always a way for you to
recall a particular episode
or like whatever changes happened so i i
don't think
um i'll go through the diffs exactly i
might skim through them
but basically i'll just talk about
what's changed um and uh you know
what the i guess decisions why they were
made and what the journey was like all
of that kind of stuff
but as i mentioned because this is kind
of a new format let me know where your
feedback is
but i'm just going to tell you guys
straight right now there is no way we
can continue
writing code line by line like that's
just not going to happen we're going to
make an engine that way
um i think that i've you know the videos
that are helpful to people
who are very much beginners and want to
write code line by line i feel like
we've done all that you know i feel like
we've moved past that
you should now be able to watch a video
like this and understand
how a system works and implement it
yourself that is my goal
that is what i think should happen and
i'm going to try my best to make that
happen for you guys i
promise so um
uh yeah so so what's happened then so
the way that shaders used to work is we
simply used to load them like from a
file and they
got immediately sent into like uh i
don't know gl like share
into opengl sharer compiler basically
the way that they work now
is very much the same if we open up
renderer2d and we take a look at
um the way that we load like this we
really only have one shader at the
moment right texture
dot glsl so if we look at assets um
you know shaders texture.jls so this is
the texture
sorry this is the shader so what i've
done first and foremost is i've actually
rewritten it
um i've rewritten it very slightly so
and actually this is where the diff
might be useful so if we look at the
diff
um what has changed so the biggest thing
that's changed is we no longer will ever
use plain kind of uniforms the reason
being
one of the big changes that we want
going forward is we want to be able to
support
vulkan as a rendering api now at the
moment
and for the you know unforeseeable
future
we're going to continue just doing
opengl hazeldev at this point in time
supports vulcan i'll leave a video up
there that you can check out if you want
to see where hazeldev is at and what
that's like and
my kind of vulcan journey i recommend
all of you guys actually watch those
hazel devlogs because
um they can be extremely useful to see
the bigger picture of engines and like
how we actually
you know do maybe more advanced stuff
because i know some people are kind of
you know wanting to move past the stuff
that we're doing here that's kind of
shown very um
very verbosely i guess very in a very
detailed fashion
but basically um because we want to
support vulcan going forward
um you know we need to be able to
support uh opengl
now because that's a decision i've made
and so we need to basically
kind of support both but i don't want to
do things in a strictly open gl only
fashion
because uh if i do that then it will
kind of lock us into opengl
for a lot longer than we need to be and
then it'll be harder to rewrite things
i'm kind of looking ahead a little bit
more
and so because of that because we need
vulcan vulcan also uses glsl
however a common misconception is that
it's the same as opengl jlsl
it is not it is different if there are
things in vulcan that don't exist in
opengl and there are things in opengl
that don't exist in vulkan
and i mean in specifically the shading
languages right a good example is
uniforms
uniforms do not work in vulcan it's not
a thing you cannot just say
uniform you know matte for
transform or whatever i don't know why
you have that in your fragment shader um
i mean i guess can be useful but anyway
unif you know you don't have this in
vulcan it doesn't exist doesn't matter
if you have a layout location for it
whatever it does not exist
right in vulcan things need to be either
as a push constant which looks like this
layout push
constant and then it's basically a
uniform buffer right so you have like
uniform transform and then you have
mat for um you know transform or
whatever
uh inside this kind of buffer um and you
probably you know would give it like a
layout and
all that kind of stuff or you have it as
an actual uniform buffer which looks
like this which looks very similar as
well
um let's not compile that uh which just
basically instead of push constant it
just has like a particular binding
right that's how uniforms work in
in falcon there are no uniforms there
are uniform buffers there are dynamic
uniform buffers and there
are push constants that is how and there
are like storage buffer that
we won't talk about some other more
advanced things because they're not
really like i'm talking about the simple
case of how do i get a matrix how do i
get a vector
from my cpu to my gpu and then access it
in the shader
and this is the answer right so because
of that
um we need to get rid of uniforms
now in the case of this i mean what do
we have here before we had a view
projection
now the thing is this you have to
realize the context of this
of this shader this is not a this is not
a 3d model kind of shader this is not
our like pbr shade that we render
our scene with we're dealing with a 2d
renderer
so this shader technically speaking will
more or less run once
right um what do i mean by run once i
don't mean i don't actually mean run
once i mean like this is more or less
going to be like one draw call maybe two
draw calls right
if we have like ten 000 i don't know
what the limit is but basically we can
render like a lot of sprites at once
right in a single draw call
that's that's the purpose of this batch
renderer 20 000 quads
so in our pink cube scene where we're
rendering three quads
that's a single draw call right so it's
not a huge impact here
but when we have a 3d scene every single
every single object every single sub
mesh most likely
unless it's batched together will be a
separate draw call we could
easily have over a thousand draw calls
now something like the view projection
matrix that's the camera
that does not change over any of those
1000 draw calls
in a single render pass let's just
pretend that we're just rendering
our render pass from the point of view
of the camera you know here are all of
the objects in our scene
that does not change right and so
because that doesn't change
you know why would we need to and and
this is the big thing though out of
those 1000 objects
it's very very common for us to have
different materials
right different materials have
potentially different shaders
right so instead of us having to have a
view projection matrix
that we set per shader as a uniform
right because usually shaders have their
own kind of uniform story again this is
an existing vulcan but
we have our own kind of uniform storage
per shader right instead of us having to
update all of the shaders in our entire
engine
what we can do instead is we can use
something called the uniform buffer
which is basically just
a way for us to be like hey gpu allocate
a block of memory for me that is
accessible by shaders
right that's what a uniform buffer is
it's a buffer of memory which we can
then
let shaders access so i can say that hey
i want to create a uniform buffer at
index zero right it's going to be my
camera buffer and then if shaders want
they can be like
hey hook me up man i want that binding
zero i want that
i want that camera buffer i need it
because i need to render
this from the point of view of the
camera right that's how uniform buffers
work the
good the good thing about them is that
they're
global across our it's a gpu thing it's
not a shader thing really
i mean it's intended to be used by
shaders but it's not like a per shader
situation no
it's just a buffer of memory on the gpu
that we can then use
inside any shader we want and again
because
something at binding zero it's it's not
like a per shader thing it's global it's
across all about all of our shaders any
shader in our whole engine can be like
binding zero uniform buffer hook me
up i want the camera view projection
matrix and it will get it right
so what that means is that now suddenly
this is entirely
separate from shaders right this camera
stuff um
is not something that we need to worry
about on a shader level it's something
that we worry about on a renderer level
so the renderer at the beginning of the
frame
can be like hey man set up my camera and
as i mentioned we switched to
using uniform buffers so what does that
look like in code we have a uniform
buffer class which we will explore in a
minute i think i'll save that for
another episode
um because i noticed that i'm already
going pretty in-depth as i mentioned
this is
it's a devlog but it's super in-depth so
let me know what you guys think of this
um because i do still i do still want to
actually you know
teach this stuff i don't want to just be
like hey this is what i've done let's
move on
that's boring right so um we might
actually explicitly look at how uniform
buffers work in a separate uh episode
but today we'll focus on like the shader
stuff
so um we create the uniform buffer and
then you can see that in like begin
it begins in um that's our job like we
know the view projection matrix the
camera and the inverse the transform or
in this case is actually just the
camera's view projection matrix
then we can just set that data onto the
gpu
and that's it right we do this once
per frame when we start a scene why
because starting a scene
is basically analog to setting a camera
right there's no we don't have like
environments so we don't have anything
like you know special like lighting
setups we just have a camera and we
render our 2d geometry from the point of
view of the camera so
setting it starting a scene is providing
a camera setting all that stuff up
that's what we're doing and then we
start the batch and then now
our shaders can just be like you know
uniform camera it's a binding zero i
want access to that view projection
matrix you can give this a name
like you know camera buffer or whatever
and then view projection
that might even be better um i don't
know why i've just written it like this
for now
um which basically if you don't give it
a name you just access it as if it's a
normal uniform
but as you can see that's what we do so
it works very similarly to what we had
before before we literally
just had this right but it means that
this
is something we need to set this uniform
for every shader that uses it
if we had a slightly different shader
that did something else
um you know we'd all would we'd also
have to give it this and we'd also have
to set
it right um and obviously the way that
we can set uniforms is by either binding
the shader by doing glues program
and then doing gl you know program sorry
gl
uh you know uniform matte matrix for fv
you know for the matrix and setting it
or we can actually just cut out the
binding
and do gl program uniform matrix for
v provide the um the shader id so the
program id that opengl gives us when we
create the shader
and then actually upload that matrix per
shader we don't have to do that anymore
we just
we just say that our shader is hooked up
to that uniform buffer
done so it that's all that's really
changed and again the reason this change
exists
if we were just doing opengl i'd still
make this change that's what uniform
buffers are for
it's for data that you share across
shaders such as like camera environment
you know maybe shadow information you
know whatever stuff that basically is
not particular
to a particular shader particular to a
particular shader
right so a camera is a good example
because we want to render a whole scene
from the point of view of the camera it
doesn't matter what material what shade
is being used
we still need to know where the camera
is so that's perfect
um now the other the other the other
stuff that's really changed here
mostly has just been like you know this
stuff so for example with this sampler
2d we've been explicit without binding
right now bindings for textures um there
are 32 of these here
but bindings for textures work uh and
again i'm not gonna i don't think i'll
spend too long
talking about this today but basically
if you have a sampler 2d let's just
ignore the array for now
i have like some kind of texture that i
want to set right
um in opengl you know it's possible for
us to just do uniform sampler 2d
and then we have to set that texture to
be like
a value so we do gl uniform 1i we set
the sampler to be like
with zero you know and by doing that it
means that we can do gl
you know gl binds texture units or gl
active texture if we're really old
school and set it to like be
you know zeros the active texture and
then i'm binding my texture
in in more modern versions of opengl and
in vulkan especially involving is
required in but in more
modern versions of opengl and jlsl it's
it's optional
you can actually just write code like
this so what that means is that i'm
setting the text unit to be zero
no more gl uniform one eye none of that
right this is texture zero right
now i think you can override it by
setting uniform one eye if you
really want to i'm not 100 sure if that
even works but my point is you can
actually just in your shader just define
you know any texture unit for this right
here in the glsl code which is great
um and in vulcan i think like in vulcan
it's mandatory that you do that
there's no such thing as setting
integers in the shader to be like
texture units or whatever and vulcan
it doesn't exist right so we have to do
it this way um also everything else has
to be
uh hooked up with certain locations so
for example we have an
out vertex output i've put this into a
struct um we've set it at location
zero we can't just say out and then
match it by name it gets matched by
location
so what that means by the way is that um
you'll notice here that
we jump from zero to four right and the
reason we do that is because
um i think it's every like every 16
bytes
occupies a slot in this location right
so vec 4 16 bytes and this is another
or maybe it's every 8 bytes because
that's 16 bytes and then this is 16
bytes
maybe it's just because of the padding
i'm not 100 sure this might be 16 bytes
that might be 8 bytes with 8 bytes of
padding
that might be four bytes with 12 bytes
of padding and then another one
um but the point is this needs to be at
location four
right because we have apparently um uh
for you know either i don't know
again as i said per 8 buys per 16 bucks
i'd have to double check the
documentation
but that's um basically what we do so
this isn't like per struct or whatever
it's dependent on the size
um and then obviously for this flat int
or whatever because we want it flat we
can't really put it into the struct we
have it outside of the struct
i'm not sure if it's necessary to have
it as flat um we are
yeah it's probably not someone just i
think someone may have done that in a
pull request i'm not sure
i've left it as flat for now um because
it shouldn't be it shouldn't change
across
um across vertex shade
sorry across vertices because it's going
to be the same object it'll always have
the same entity id
so i don't think it's going to
interpolate over it i mean it might try
and maybe that's what flat does
prevents it from trying in this case
because even if it did interpolate it
would wind up with the exact same value
because the entity id is going to be
constant across all these vertices
but anyway so the point is we have to
include these locations
um
yeah i think everything else we
basically had the same right so again
referring to this
nothing else really changed it's just we
put this stuff into a structure now
we gave it a location because everything
needs to have like a binding or a
location
um and that looks pretty good to me so
that's basically we can just mark that
as done
so that's that is basically the
shader changes that have been made um to
the actual shader
so as i mentioned we're now compiling
vulcan shaders so what on earth does
that look like in the pipeline how does
it work
so instead of grabbing this text and
sending it to opengl into like gl
i don't even know what it is jill shader
source or whatever whatever the function
is
right we don't do that anymore instead
we use something called spur v
now spur v is a shader compiler it
compiles
into uh this kind of intermediate uh
byte code right
so um what i want to do is just show
this
right um you might want to look at this
you will you will want to look at this
if you've never heard of spurve before
but it's basically um it's like this
whole like shader
ecosystem i guess um that's a nice way
of putting it
um so it's it's okay standard portable
intermediate representation it's
basically like a shader
it's it's like some intermediate shader
presentation
right and then what you can do with this
kind of shader code
is you can do a lot using the tools that
spurvey provides you with
or you can just flat out be like the
spurvy byte code i'm going to give it
to opengl right so um
basically the pipeline looks like this
you you grab this text
you compile it with spur v right we're
using shader c in this case which is
like a google compile
google shared compiler i think um that
seems to be what everyone's using so
we're using this library
shader c to actually compile it into
spur v and then we're using a
few of the chronos provided spur v
libraries to actually uh reflect on that
shader code meaning we can actually
once we compile this to that byte code
which is originally just binary just a
bunch of bytes right
um it's almost like when you compile uh
c plus into like a translation unit and
it becomes like a dot object file
obj file or whatever kind of like that
right um it's a little bit more high
level though i think than
than like machine instructions but um
uh basically once you have it in that
format you can reflect on it meaning i
can pull out information
about like you know what uniforms does
it have what uniform buffers like what
uniform buffers do we have do we have
any push constants
um i haven't talked about push constants
but i probably won't for now because
we're not using them
um oh no i did talk about push constants
loosely uh you know
what textures do we have what resources
do we have available to us inside the
shader we can reflect on it which is
fantastic from a validation point of
view because we can make sure
that we have um everything we need and
for certain things like
you know push constants as an example
because that's usually where
where we would want to have our material
kind of uniforms
right our material properties material
you know variables whatever
we can actually ask it what do you have
available
how many biases take up what are they
called stuff like that and then we can
create a material system around that
which is what hazeldev does
so um that's fantastic but then also we
have the ability once it's in that
spurvy format to cross compile it to
anything else
i can i can take this code compile it
with spervy into the spurvy binary right
then i can cross compile it into
metal the metal shading language or into
hlsl
directx shading language right or into
you know in this case we're actually
using that
to convert it into an opengl compatible
glsl so as i mentioned this is vulcan
glsl
right i mean at the moment this should
work in opengl but as soon as i start
introducing
introducing things like push constants
so if i have a little push constant here
called transform maybe
and it actually does contain my
transform right what will happen here
well this is not
opengl jlsl what's a push constant right
doesn't work
but what we can do is we can still
compile this into vulcan
glsl to vulcan spur v then take that
vulcan spervy binary
and open it up in like spur v cross
which is the cross compiler
and tell it compile it for opengl and
what it will actually do
is generate glsl text that we can read
it'll look like this
that will now be
compatible with opengl right and then we
can send that
into v again if we wanted to guess
get a spurvy binary and then just do gl
shader binary to
send that binary to open gel or we could
take the text directly and put it into
opengl right just the same way we were
doing
before which is just reading text and
putting it into opengl right
telling you that this is my shader
source code please compile it for me but
it's better to do it with spur v
because um you'll actually apart from
getting more metadata and more
information if you need it
you can easily cache that onto disk and
then you can
read that cache right um at any point
instead of having to go through this
process again
so basically once you've decided this is
my shader i'll i'll compile it
you can write that binary result the
binary shader to disk
and then never look at the source code
again and you can ship that if you want
because the shaders
might not change it might change if you
have like dynamic shader compilation
maybe stuff depends on you know whatever
but
if you have those binaries that's it and
it'll be way faster because it's not
going to have to look through this code
and compile it do anything
you're not going to have to open or read
text files right it's just
it's going to be in that format you can
give it to you know gel shader binary
and then you're good so basically
that's how this works that's how the
hazel pipeline works
we take vulcan glsl code we compile it
using spur v
into a binary file we then
take that binary file that vulcan
compatible binary file
we fit it into the spervy cross compiler
that gives us an
opengl compatible glsl text file
or just a string we take that string we
compile it using spervy but this time
for opengl
and then we uh you know cache both both
of those binaries to disk
um and we can now give that to opengl
using gel shader binary
one step that i missed there was the
reflection step because
spur v is kind of made for vulcan um we
actually
can't you know
one okay so in this scenario let's talk
about this so what does this actually
become an opengl if push constants are
not supported
well what it will actually do is first
of all we can give our push constant
our name right so i could be like you
transform or you
render a uniforms or whatever transform
right
um let's pretend it's that and we can
access it you know as you would here
maybe if you were rendering a 3d model
you'd
multiply it with like you know this as
an example
um we can actually uh take this
right um or what spervy cross rather
will do is it will take this and it'll
be like okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make a struct for you i'm going to call
the struct transform
right and then i'm going to add your
little transform into the struct
right and then i'm going to make
a uniform transform
urandra uniforms so basically this
becomes that
it just becomes a plain old uniform but
it's a struct
which is obviously fine and valid jsl
right so that's
what the spervy cross compiler will do
with push constants
now can we then ask the shader via
reflection
tell me what your uniform is opengl
actually has its own reflection
functions but when we're trying not to
use them because again
trying not to stay in the opengl
ecosystem too much but um
can we do that with spervy reflect the
answer is no
we can't look at these uniforms why well
they didn't really exist in vulcan not
really worth i guess
i don't know why they didn't support
them but they didn't what we can do
though is we can
inquire about push constants so the way
this actually works
is even though we're using opengl we're
compiling using vulkan
um you know vulcan oh sorry we're
compiling vulcan gelson to eva
into a vulcan spervy binary and then
we're taking that spurvy binary and
reflecting on it
so even though we're then later cross
compiling it into glsl into opengl
jlsell
and then using that in opengl so we
still need that vulcan binary we still
have to have it so that we can reflect
on it and find out information about
like oh you have a push constant which
for opengl we know becomes this
right um but you can see the naming is
the same you know you render a dot
transform
you render uniforms.transform you know
it works obviously for both shading
languages
um okay so does that also mean then
that if we have vulcan there's another
stage to this i i don't think i will get
into this too much
but basically um another thing that we
use and another thing that we do in
hazel dev
um is uh and see this is why it's so
useful you know i i love the hazel dev
project because apart from
that being kind of me making my own
engine without like you know having to
like teach it every step of the way and
thus not getting
very far um apart from that it's also
really useful for this series because
obviously
now i have a much more detailed idea of
the bigger picture
so because um this is a good example
there are some cases in opengl
sorry there are some cases in your glsl
code where the actual physical glsl code
might have to be different between
opengl and vulkan
right so i'm talking about like
calculations so
it might be desirable for for us to do
something like if instead of running two
different shaders which we never want to
do that's why we do this whole thing by
the way
we want to support opengl and vulkan and
maybe directx in the future maybe metal
in the future who knows
but we don't want to write our shaders
multiple times
so what we do instead is we use we write
it in one format such as vulcan glsl
which i'll admit is not i would probably
choose hlsl if i had to choose a format
but since we don't have any plans at all
for supporting directx like ever
um you know because the only reason we'd
need to is if we wanted to ship on like
xbox which i don't think we're gonna do
um anytime soon at least
and if we do in the fin i don't know we
can add we can always add it
but anyway um and so it doesn't make
much too much sense for me to use hlself
whenever supporting direct acts
um so uh basically what i was saying was
that
um with this vulcan jealous uh with with
vulcan um it might be uh
with the whole vulcan such opengl thing
it might i don't know where like why i
started this conversation
but basically it might be desirable for
us to actually um you know instead of
writing our shaders twice once for
opengl once for
once uh for vulcan if the
um actual content like the calculations
have to be different
we can use preprocessor like arguments
you know directives instead
so we can actually write a little thing
such as like into you know value equals
zero
float value equals zero and then if
opengl maybe value maybe we normalize it
or like we put into a different range
you know so we say
something like this value equals value
times 0.5 plus 0.5
you know just for opengl um or something
i don't know i'm making stuff up but the
point is um
we can easily do this using preprocessor
directives
but that means that when we compile our
vulcan
code we actually need to compile it with
this flag
because obviously you know when we cross
compile it since it's using that spurvy
binary this stuff will have already been
evaluated
so basically what i'm saying is that we
can't simply take the vulcan spur v
and then feed it into the cross compiler
from the beginning of the pipeline from
the text
we need to be like this is an opengl
vulcan
spur v binary so that actually does have
a bit of an effect
on the way that we like cache these
binary files and all that stuff
um a real world example of this by the
way is um vulcan actually has a
different depth range
opengl has negative one to one uh for
its like depth
uh vulcan has zero to one what that
means is that for some calculations you
know when for example we do like shadows
and we have to
um you know calculate the right um
you know once we look up the shadow map
and we want to actually calculate the
correct depth from the point of view of
the camera versus the point of view of
the light we have to
remember in vulcan to put it into a
different
range or rather in opengl to put it to a
different range
than when we're dealing with vulcan so
that's a that's an example of a real
world kind of
use of why we might want to actually
have different calculations
um you can obviously have if you wanted
to like some kind of uniform
and that would be like the modifier you
know i
i like doing it more in the glsl code um
because it makes a little bit more sense
i think and you don't need to like use
up a uniform slot or anything
um okay anyway so let's take a look at
this is
again becoming a huge video but we
haven't had a gaming series episode in a
while so i hope you guys are enjoying
this
the next step is going to be um probably
to look at what actually happens in the
shader
so as i mentioned the shader um this is
a bit annoying but whatever
um all these increases and line and
endings the shader um
actually uh has like had the most
changes i think like if you look at this
diff
you know this is all the stuff that's
changed basically everything the whole
file has pretty much changed
i basically rewritten it um it also used
to be like 187 lines now it's like 374.
so
it's been expanded has been rewritten
what happens now
well we again as you saw the api stays
the same
this part did not change this whole idea
of like um
you know we're creating a texture shader
with this gel cell code that doesn't
change
um we don't really need to be doing this
by the way i haven't actually even
tested this with textures
this doesn't need to be done anymore in
fact i can just get rid of this um this
isn't
like 100 done let's just see if this
works because we are actually using
the white texture as texture slot zero
um so there you go see i
slam writing code in front of you guys
that will never change i guess
or rather deleting code um
pink cube okay that does still work so
if it wasn't a white texture we probably
wouldn't see anything
if the texture wasn't working because it
multiplies the color with the texture
and if it was missing most likely we'd
have black and
we just would not show up or it would be
black
anyway so this doesn't change right so
what actually happens
um is we still obviously support that we
take in a file path
um and then the first thing we actually
do is we create the cache directory if
needed so as i mentioned it's very slow
for us to
recompile all of these text shaders
every time we run hazel that's just
that's not needed right every time the
shader changes we do need to do that
and at the moment we're not detecting
changes we're basically just saying hey
does the cache exist if yes
use the cached binary file um so this is
us create creating
that cache directory right just to make
sure
this doesn't need to be here there used
to be two no there's one
um so the cage directory is going to be
assets k shader opengl
and again for future apis we might have
like you know vulcan here
um whatever at the moment it's just
opengl make sure assets directory is
valid
apparently it's yeah to make sure that
the assets directory is actually assets
because it might not be in the future
um then we just see if that exists and
then if not um we can use the brilliant
c417 file system api to create
recursively all
directories along the way to make this
path happen which is amazing
i love that um so that's what this does
just to make sure it's there because if
we try and write a file and the
directory doesn't exist
it won't be able to then we read the uh
source and we pre-process it which means
we split it up into the different
um source codes because as you know we
still have this type vertex type
fragment of the whole cherno shading
language situation
um so that's what that does that has not
changed now i actually hook this up with
a timer to see how long it takes but
basically these are the three steps
compile or get vulcan binaries that
takes in the
shader sources which is the actual
string source code
for each opengl type right so again you
know we have
uh you know like a vertex header
fragment shader that's what the type is
um we create a shader c compiler we look
at the
uh you know we set the options um in
this case what we're doing is we're just
setting the options to basically be
vulkan 1.2 so we're compiling for vulcan
1.2 as i mentioned right
um in these options it would be a
fantastic place
to actually add a macro definition like
i mentioned of opengl
right so you can just be like you know
what um you know we're
defining opengl and you would have to do
that for the vulcan version here
because as i mentioned the preprocessor
is going to run you're going to lose all
your text
so you have to do it there optimization
you can set to false
i don't know why we would ever not
optimize in this case
um but whatever um and then we set it to
performance just a little flag here
uh could be based on some input
parameters whatever
um then we just get the cache directory
and we basically compile all of the
different shader sources
ignoring the cache um we
uh basically create a module here and we
just do compiler.compile glsl to spur v
we just pass in our arguments basically
i don't think anything here is
useful we have our stage we just convert
that into shader c so
vertex shader becomes shader c or cell
vertex shader fragment shader becomes
that
pretty simple stuff um if the
compilation doesn't succeed we print the
error message as usual
and then we actually have the shader
data inside a
vector of words it likes to use the
un32ts instead of bytes here
um and then we write it out using the
output stream someone convinced me to
use
the simples api instead of file i think
in hazel dev
it's just file and fopen because that's
how i roll but
um i guess we'll be c level 17 c plus
plus e
here um and we'll do this i think it
mostly just
wraps um
i think this mostly just wraps the api
anyway and i've lost it
maybe not here but i'm pretty sure it
does
probably not worth me doing this now but
you might have to take my word for it
basic of stream
basic oh stream the hardest part is just
trying to find all of this stuff to be
honest
especially when you're rushing
no okay whatever um it's definitely got
some more like validation
and uh safety stuff around it okay so um
then we've got uh yeah so once we have
created that we cache it to disk right
and that's what this brought this branch
over here does
if the cache exists we read it we open
it and we
now have our data if not we compile it
and we well we still have our data so it
gets written
and then once we have all the shaders
all the shader stages done and compiled
which is what this code does we can
reflect on it so what does that do
i keep trying to build um so what
reflection does at the moment
is mostly just printing stuff we don't
actually use the reflection yet we will
in the future for materials just to see
what's available
and potentially for validation as well
but what this does at the moment
is it's just a demonstration of um how
this whole reflection works
so you can see open javascript reflect
and we actually uh print you know the
file path the shader stage
to string that just basically you know
converts that to a string
unifor how many uniform buffers do we
have and you can see we can use this
perfect cross
api here once we've reflected over it
compiler gets shaded resources
to actually see how many uniform buffers
it has how many sampled images it has so
like textures right
what are the uniform buffers what are
the names of the uniform buffers how big
are they
what we can actually even iterate
through the members if we want you know
what's the binding
set to right is it zero is it one you
know we can see all that stuff here
and this is just a little example to
show you guys how the reflection works
so the way i write this code as well is
is i try and um
almost explain it in the code itself so
again you should now be able to
hopefully look at this reflect function
and be like
ah this is how i can find out
potentially the information that i need
and then write that code in my own
engine um so
i'm trying to be extra kind of a burst
descriptive with my code i'm not trying
to be all
you know four into x equals y
w is less than z you know cryptic stuff
this is supposed to be very um
easy to read hopefully that's my goal
with this code anyway
and of course these explanations
hopefully if you can be bothered sitting
through
40 minutes it better not be running out
of disk space because that would be the
worst no i'm so good
um okay so where were we
yeah that's this stage then we do the
compiler get opengl binaries
so what does that do well the same thing
but um
so we have the vulcan binaries now we
have them we've either loaded them from
disk
and done reflection on them i should
really move reflect out of the compile
function don't know why it's here we'll
do that later
um we we already have the welcome ones
we we've
we've either actually compiled them and
then written them to disk or we've read
them from disk
so now what do we do um to do read from
cache i think we already do that
it's probably done compile compile well
what i don't know i'm getting rid of
that
so um we have uh this is just i think
the um
where it goes but basically what does
this do
same thing so except in this case right
um oh where
is where does the cross compilation
happen i think we've done that or does
it happen here yeah it probably happens
yeah it happens here
okay so this time though we create a new
compiler and we set it to be opengl and
opengl 4.5 instead of vulkan vulcan 1.2
um and i think uh 4.5 is the latest by
the way so there's no like 4.6
currently no difference between opengl
4.5 and 4.6
so there you go and just lang doesn't
accept an original client of 460.
okay that's why our shaders as well uh
obviously 450 core stop
telling me about this i should have okay
whatever
um so we go through the vulcan spervy we
either read the binary if it's already
on the disk right
um so this is by the way uh as we're
going through the velcro spur v
this is us reading um the
uh gl shader stage k shape and gel file
extension this is us reading not the
vulcan
stuff we've already got that that's what
the vulcan stage was for this is us
trying to read the opengl cached binary
if we have one
if we don't we go over here so if we
don't we cross compile
we're taking the vulcan spur v which
comes from here we're going through the
vulcan spur v
even though we're trying to retrieve the
opengl spervy we're going through the
vulcan spur v
um and then we're cross compiling it
into um opengl and how we do that we do
a compiler glsl
and then i think by default this will
just be set to be like an opengl
compatible one i believe
um
i think yeah so version 450
um and vulcan semantics is false by
default right so it's not going to use
vulcan jealously features it's going to
use gl compatible features
because it's false and there's a few
other things you can do here
actually which is really useful i
haven't looked at this too much because
we have a
pretty simple example i think some of
these might be used in hazel dev
specifically but we basically compile
that source code it gets saved into
opengl source code so we have these two
things we have opengl
source code we save that just so we can
for debug reasons
view what the cross compiler generated
what text it generated
but otherwise you can see we have our
vulcan and opengl spervy we also at the
moment retain all this in memory you
don't need this in memory once you've
reflected and once you've
uh compiled and sent it to the you know
to opengl
but we still keep it for now just for
debugging purposes um
yeah we compile that um yeah so we've
cross compiled it we now have the text
and then we send the text into jlsell
just like we did originally with our
original textbook for vulcan
right so hopefully all this is making
sense uh read through the code
um and you can run it with a breakpoint
and with debugger
that might help as well um and then we
cache it to disk so what does that mean
that means that as you saw me run that
first of all let's take a look at this
the assets directory has a cache
directory
right and inside the cache directory
there's a shader directory
um opengl like you saw and then we have
four files
we have the opengl.vert.frag and we have
the vulkan.vert.frag right
if i delete these or in fact we can test
it by just deleting the whole case
directory
right it will have to recompile all of
them from text and at the moment
because we're not detecting changes by
like hashing the string or whatever
hashing the binary
um it will that's the only way if you
change your shader you have to delete
the cached one
or or maybe i'll set it like in hazel
dev there's a force compiled flag that
you can give
anyway as you saw that took wow 6.8
seconds
usually takes about five seconds i don't
know why it's suddenly slower but that's
how long it takes to compile everything
um now
uh and you can see that we've got
uniform buffers and the reflection has
worked here as well we have one uniform
buffer it doesn't have a name
i didn't actually give it a name as you
know i was just um
using um you know i didn't give it a
name the name would go here
right so it's generated its own name but
we know that um
look it's got a matrix called view
projection in it that's what we see here
we have size 64 binding zero one member
right so we can get access to that we
could print the names as well it is
trying to print the name of the uniform
buffer it's had to make one because we
haven't given it one
but anyway 6.8 seconds that's how long
it took to launch and to compile all
this
now watch how long it takes if i run it
again
instant right 19 milliseconds
right huge difference 6.8 seconds 19
milliseconds right so that's why it's so
important to cash your shaders
um we don't want to you know spend a lot
of time compiling shaders
um and then you can open up your pink
cube um
and everything is great that's basically
the major system um again i'm not i
haven't talked about uniform buffers but
that's what we do now
with our shaders we compiled them using
that um now the final stage which i
didn't touch on was the creating the
program
and i apologize for this hugely long
video um
maybe i'll break them up in the future a
bit more i just didn't think i would be
able to talk so much about this
um stuff anyway i hope it's i hope this
level of depth though is good because i
know that a lot of people
did still want it to be very in-depth um
we create the program the same way and
then we just go through all the
stages right and we get inside the
opengl spur v
and then what do we do gel shader binary
right we just say binary format spur v
this is obviously the opengl spurvy not
the vulcan spervy
we do gel specialized shader that just
points it to the main function there's a
few other things here
like specialization constants and stuff
like that
but the entry point is the important one
that we need to give
we're using actual specializations um
then we attach it to the program we link
the program as before this part is
identical to before and then we just
link it and do all of that stuff
delete the shader ids to detach the
shader oh sorry delete them if they fail
i think we
also should delete the shaders um here
let's just try that let's detach and
then delete um
we can obviously group those two uh four
loops together but i'm just curious if
this
if this works
um i mean i assume so i think this is
what we were doing before
the program can't be deleted but these
individual shader objects should be i
think
so let's uh do detach and delete
like that uh and we've saved ourselves a
comment we can get rid of the comment
brilliant so um yeah and then this part
as i mentioned
that remains the same so not much has
like
not not like everything has changed it's
still kind of the input and output of
this class is identical
right it's just the actual this the
contents of it has changed
we still have all of these uniforms
you know we can keep them like these
functions but again
um they're going to be very open gel
specific so we will probably end up
getting rid of them eventually but that
is basically currently
how the shader system works um i don't
want to go through
uh there's a few different things i want
to go through i will commit all this
code so you guys can take a look at it
i have a lot of other stuff to talk
about i just didn't not realize as i
mentioned this would be so long
but um uh
yeah i think there's also like
so another huge thing that i want to
talk about which i'll talk about in the
next video actually
is our whole dependency on the vulcan
sdk so this uses the vulcan sdk vulcan
actually ships with all these tools
to be able to compile this stuff and you
know which is great um the vulcan sdk
uh has two types of libraries we could
compile ourselves
well some of these libraries ourselves
um i don't really want to
um i think that it might be something
that we might have to do in the future
for like different platforms
um but for now for windows there are
pre-compiled binaries now these
pre-compiled binaries
are very big and obviously we need debug
binaries and release binaries the debug
binaries are two and a half gigabytes i
don't want to commit them
into the project that will massively
inflate our get repository size
so instead we are you have to download
them basically
from kronos but i've written some
scripts to do that
and that's what we'll talk about next
time so anyway hope you guys enjoyed
this video
if you did please don't forget to hit
the like button patreon.com the channel
best way to help support
everything everything that i'm doing
here 50 minutes i've been recording for
i don't know what the edited video will
be like probably very close
to that let me know what you thought of
this kind of new format
um you can kind of see
i hope that the fact that this has taken
50 minutes to explain
um this took me like i don't know how
many hours of actual work maybe four or
five hours of actual work i
have done this stuff before and hazeldev
does very similar stuff as well
uh but it was live stream so you can
catch the live streams or you can go
through the backlog on patreon as well
and take a look at that i've labeled
them like game engine series live stream
or whatever so
you should be able to find them um but
uh you can see how hopefully how if i
had
actually done this for the first time or
whatever or written all the code in
front of you
um it would have taken a little longer
and i don't think it
would have been worth it because i think
i i personally think this kind of
reflection way
of doing things is um hopefully going to
be more useful
to more people but anyway leave your
thoughts in the comment section below
please thank you all for your support
um and i'll see you next time have a
good day
[Music]
you